the rumor mill's been in overdrive for
days who's in prime minister
planning big changes
and during pmqs the news finally broke a
cabinet reshuffle on its way if you see
the panto season
the pm planning to recast these
characters some hoping for bigger roles
others worrying about being forced out
of the limelight
bad news for some summoned to the pm's
parliamentary office leaving without a
job
education secretary gavin williamson
failed to make the grade leaving
government after presiding over a
chaotic period for school children
during the pandemic gone to housing
secretary robert generic and justice
secretary robert buckland also sacked
the hardest part done in the pm back to
number 10. we know who's out but who's
him
dominic rob fast to the door keeping a
cabinet seat but not as foreign
secretary instead he moves to justice a
bitter pill to swallow sweetened by
formal role as deputy pm what is your
new job
michael gove newly in charge of housing
if this government's really going to
build back better he'll need to make
progress are you pleased with your new
job
and liz trust our new foreign secretary
the first conservative woman to take on
that role how are you feeling relief
survival for ben wallace the performance
of the army in the evacuation of kabul
cementing his role at the mod i am very
privileged to be going back to one of
the greatest departments of government
and a big promotion for steve barkley
he'll head up the cabinet office how are
you feeling about your promotion yeah
delighted looking forward to it
and we're going to be very busy what do
you think it says about the pm's
priorities this reshuffle ensuring that
post kobe would take the innovation
and drive up through government i'm
looking forward to doing so the new
trade secretary given her view on
proceedings what do you think of the
reshuffle so far does it feel like a
reset of his government so i think we're
bringing uh you know great minds into
place where i know the prime minister
has some really
passionate desires to make change bring
reform and move the government and move
the country forward
while some key roles are unchanged the
chancellor home and health secretaries
remain the same there's no doubt that
this is a major reshuffle what it shows
ours is that the prime minister is
determined to move beyond the kovic
crisis that's defined the past 18 months
of his government he wants to reboot an
administration that's barely even got
going with a focus on his domestic
agenda health housing education and
leveling up
on the front foot in this new
parliamentary term this a prime minister
high on confidence and show in his power
we know what he wants to achieve the
real challenge now is to deliver it beth
rigby sky news westminster